le césar du meilleur film est attribué à
dio les cons sept césars le grand
vainqueur de cette soirée c'est lui les
lycéens les professionnels sont tombés
d'accord c'est la première victoire
d'albert dupontel dans cette catégorie
après deux nominations infructueuses
pour neuf mois ferme en 2014 et au
revoir là où en 2018 vous demande tout
de suite à l'équipe du film de me
rejoindre sur scène un énorme merci
est-ce que sidonie dumas peut monter sur
scène ainsi que virginie s'il te plaît
nicolas ainsi que l'équipe du film
merci mais a pris bâton
oui lors il y avait deux césars en fait
et je parle donc pas je suis aussi très
heureuse de ce prix et je suis heureux
d'avoir tourné dans ce film d'albert je
le remercie pour ça pour sa croyance et
son amour aiguë fort puissant du cinéma
je cède ma place
bon évidemment albert tu nous manque ce
soir mais bravo bravo pour ce film
exceptionnel
je suis trop impatiente que les salles
réouvre il ce film a été une entreprise
une semaine et plus de 700 mille entrées
donc il faut que tous les autres qui
veulent aller le voir vous allez le voir
le plus rapidement possible merci merci
beaucoup merci bravo
[Applaudissements]